my name is Erica I'm a senior zate
engineer at the urban Institute um and
the urban Institute is a nonprofit
research organization that provides data
and evidence to help Advance upward
mobility and Equity today I'll be
talking about a tool that my co-workers
at the urban Institute and I built
called the Education data portal before
I get started I have a confession to
make which is that I am very much not an
education data expert in fact I know
very little about Education data luckily
I'm not here today to talk about the ins
and outs of iPads or common core data
and instead what I'm here to talk about
is how the Education data portal Bridges
the gap between data availability and
data
accessibility specifically there are
three questions that I want to answer
today the first is what do we mean by
this gap between data availability and
accessibility the second how does the
portal bridge this Gap so
effectively and lastly why does this
matter so every year a handful of
government agencies do the hard and
important work of collecting detailed
data on K through 12 schools school
districts and then colleges in the US
the goal of the Education data portal is
to put all of this data under a single
roof by providing a freely available
One-Stop shop for all of the major
national data sets released by these
agencies um in many cases these agencies
have been collecting this data for a
couple decades and as you can imagine
there have been lots of changes to data
formats file structures classifications
over the years so our goal is to do um
the hard work of harmonizing that data
that way um we can do that work and
offload that from the um offload that
from researchers and um data science and
other folks trying to use that data when
I say wether I really mean our army of
research assistants who do that hard
work so um much kudos to them ultimately
we do this to make it easier for both
Technical and non-technical users to
look at Trends over time and combine
data from these different sources and
just to put that data at their
fingertips a little
easier so this is a little bit abstract
so um to provide an example suppose I'm
interested in answering the question of
how is tuition and my Al the matter
risen over the last couple decades my
case so I went to a tiny little liberal
arts college Northfield Minnesota called
Carlton um and like many other
delightful little liberal arts colleges
I probably have a ref sense the tuition
over the last couple decades looks
something like this however as I
mentioned at the beginning I work for
the urban Institute and we take data and
evidence very seriously so I'm not just
going to you know use my priors here and
suppose I want to really get into the
data and try to reproduce this plot
myself so first suppose I live in a
world without the Education data portal
um I'm also going to be showing a live
look at my pain levels they go through
the process of answering this question
without the Education data portal um the
very first thing I'd have to do is just
figure out which agency is collecting
this data as mentioned the beginning not
an education data expert so I just have
to do some Googling figure out which
website to go to get to that
website next I'd have to read through
the data documentation assuming that
website has data documentation for me to
read to figure out what tables am I
looking for which variables um maybe
I'll type the keyword tuition into you
know some kind of a query and then get a
couple hundred or a couple thousand
tables back to figure out just which
where is the data that I'm looking for
on this website
next i' have to download individual data
files for each year so I think for folks
who are um used to work with government
data agencies typically typically report
data as like CSV files or um depending
on the programming language you're using
stas or staa files which can be great if
you use those languages um but it also
means that in my case i' have to
download 20 some individual data files
which again not the end of the world a
little bit annoying but you move on so
next I would load those files into the
programming language of my
choice I would this is what I like to
call the choose your own data mishap
trauma um but I think you can think of
any number of things happening here
maybe it's that in the late 90s a
variable definition change um or maybe
earlier on there were three different
files for this data but then turns out
later there are two or later one um
maybe there is a 99 value for tuition
and well I think it would great V gr of
Carlton tuition cost $99 that more
likely means that um it was a total row
or like missing data or some kind of
encoding so at this point you can either
cry or you can reread the data
documentation um figure out what you did
wrong figure out what you need to redo
update your
code the very fun part of setting
yourself a calendar reminder to a year
from now do the same thing go to the
government website download that data
file and last but certainly not least
hope that nothing
changes hopefully I've belor the point
that this process is really tedious it's
really error prone and simp not
fun so enter the Education data portal
suppose you're an R user like I think
lots of folks in this room might be
great we built an r package for you
called Education data you can download
it from cray well just a single function
call it's the get Education data
function for a single call to G
Education data function um you can get a
plot that looks remarkably similar to
what I had in my brain at the very
beginning of this suppose you're not an
R an R user and said you're a python
user great we also build a package for
you less great is that's not yet
publicly available but it will be soon
but again very very similar syntax very
very similar and just being a little bit
now a little a lot bit easier um easier
to get this
data suppose you are not an R python
user instead you're a sta user and I
recognized I'm at a conference
evangelizing open source technology and
sta is very much not an open source
technology um but ultimately in the
space I work in I work with a lot of
economists I work with a lot of policy
re researchers um and again you can see
which is the fewer lines of code than uh
the r in Python syntax similar plots
pre-labeled which is great um so yeah
again just kindy to make that data a
little bit more accessible for
them suppose
you oh gosh suppose you are not a
programmer and instead you're someone
who maybe just wants to click a couple
of buttons toggle a couple um toggle a
couple things specify the
uh specify the state or the time frame
that you're interested in and just get
an ex solid spreadsheet so again this is
really looking at that nontechnical user
someone who doesn't know R doesn't know
python doesn't make sense for them to
learn those languages um they just want
to click a couple buttons and get data
as an Excel spreadsheet great we also
built a tool for them um that's what
this looks
like so hopefully made clear that I
personally think the Education data
portal does a really good job of
bridging this gap between data
availability so that's the agency or
that's the data that these agencies are
publishing um and data accessibility so
that's really putting that data at the
fingertips of the r programmer the
python programmer um the data Explorer
user so the second thing I want to talk
about today is how do I think the portal
Bridge is a scap so
effectively specifically I think it's
because it focuses on two things the
underlying API and then data
documentation I'll talk about these in
more
detail so I think in contrast these
agencies is they mentioned before who
typically publish data as Splat files
that's like CSP files or things like
that or in programming language specific
files the Education data portal really
has an API at its foundation or a
language agnostic API at its
foundation so this includes a couple of
things first it includes the actual data
endpoints that's around 110 115 and
endpoints that actually contain the data
so that's tuition data that's the
finance data that's um the actual data
that users use
it also includes um about a dozen
metadata endpoints so these are API
endpoints about the data so that's
information like um what years are
available or what variables are Avail
what variables exist for an endpoint um
or what values like what are the special
values for each of the variables um
there's a lot of reasons why focusing on
the underlying API here is very helpful
um but I think the main reason for us
and the main reason for us is just for a
lot of these data sets they're really
big just in terms of um I also realiz
that big is like a very much of a
spectrum but they're really big in terms
of the um the they're really big for the
folks who are trying to do the things
they're trying to do with this data and
I mean that both in terms of the number
of rows and then also the number of
columns um so I think it's pretty it's
not uncommon for rows to for rows of
data if you think about um I don't know
disaggregated data by like race
ethnicity sex uh institution um then
maybe also like the type of like the
major or something like that you can
easily get into the tens or hundreds of
millions of rows here which again for a
lot of people that really isn't big data
but for some people actually for a lot
of people it's just more data than as
easy to work with in um the conventional
languages they used to work with or
conventional Frameworks um by virtually
building an API you don't have to
download that 10 million row CSV file
instead if you're only interested in
data from Carlton college or from
Minnesota or for computer science Majors
you can specify through query string
print is exactly which rows do you need
through the filters and you just grab
those from a database um without having
to download the exact files just make it
a little bit easier for users to only
get the data that they need similarly
you can specify the columns you need so
if you only need um tuition you only
need the name of the institution you
don't have to get all 100 100 plus um
variables that a lot of these agencies
typically includeing the data files that
they start
with and the last thing that I think
personally and selfishly is the best
thing about having this Focus be on the
underlying API is that all of the other
tools packages and documentation are
built directly from these endpoints so
what that means is that I don't have to
spend all day every day um maintaining
stated packages and art packages and
Tableau dashboards and JavaScript sites
all I have to do is really make sure
that the API is fast it's reliable
that's accurate and my virt of having
this single source of truth I just
freeze up a lot of my time to not have
to deal with all these other things that
are going
on so the second thing that I think the
DAT the Education data portal does
really well that I think really provides
a major value added over the um existing
data that exist the existing data is
that it really treats data documentation
as a first order feature and a first
order value ad and not as an
afterthought where I think data
documentation and documentation General
tends to fall um so I was told that
showing a slide with 1400 variables
wouldn't be very aesthetically pleasing
um so instead I'm going to focus on two
things that I think really uh just
provide a lot of value the first is that
the data documentation really is written
for both humans and machines and for
anyone who's seen Johnny Johnny Bryan's
um great talk on naming things I think a
lot of the same principles about
thinking about um who your end user is
whether that is a human or a machine and
think about making your work accessible
to them I think that also really applies
to documentation here especially data
documentation dictionaries and this
second thing is that the documentation
really provides the user with details on
demand and this is barf M design
principle and I'll talk about both these
in a little bit more detail
now um so when I say data documentation
is written for both humans and machines
here's an example of a variable um
degree of urbanization um I as a human
think this is written for me like I
think I know what is telling me I have
the relevant information it's pretty um
user friendly for someone looking at it
here's that same documentation um or
data documentation but provided in a way
that I think is machine readable so by
making an API U they making an API call
to the API variables metadata endpoint
that I mentioned earlier you can get the
exact same information so you get the
label you get the data type and then you
got standardized formats of the values
um written in a way that's for machines
so there are a couple obvious advantages
of this maybe you're someone who's
trying to make hundreds of plots and
want to automate adding labels or maybe
you're someone who wants to add captions
or you're building a dashboard I me
there are n numbers of things that you
can do that really get a lot of value
from having um this data documentation
be written again both for humans on the
left and also in a in a way that can be
programmatically access on the
right the second thing I want to talk
about in the data documentation front is
that provides the user with details on
demand so here you can see that same
variable by um hovering over the tool
tip a little information tool tip you
can see that before 2005 there were nine
types of urban Centric locals and after
2005 the variable switched which again
there are lots of folks for whom that's
really important information for them
they really need to know that which is
great there's also lots of folks who
that just isn't relevant information for
them so if this was something like a PDF
um or an HTML table if I'm someone who's
just trying to quickly scan a page
figure out what table am I looking for
what variables am I looking for having
all of this information just there for
you really affects the user's ability to
just quickly scam so instead I'm
providing this user or providing users
with this detail on demand as opposed to
just there for you I think it really
provides a huge value ad for um making
this the first sort of feature and value
ad so I think implicit within this focus
on both the underlying API and the data
documentation is that the Education data
portal really is a collaboration of
folks with really deep education
expertise that's Erica J and Leo as I
mentioned on the the bottom these are
folks who have been using this data for
years in some cases decades who really
know the ins and outs of when variables
change what that means in terms of
implications um and then it also means
that there a collaboration with folks
like me who on the technology side who I
couldn't tell you what the majority of
acronyms mean um when I do I usually get
them wrong what I do know how to do is
do things like make fast apis or build
dockerized applications um and more
importantly I also know how to work with
the folks in the education team and vice
versa I think by really having that um
mutual respect for what we both bring to
the table I really think that just makes
for a stronger um yeah just a stronger
and better
tool so last and final thing I want to
talk about today is why bridging this
Gap matters and ultimately I think it
matters because different people ask
different questions so now I get to do
what I think is my favorite part of the
job which is talking to real users and
seeing what they're doing um with data
from the Education data portal so the
first example I want to talk about is an
organization we worked with called
reboot representation and they're a
nonprofit that's committed to increasing
the number of black Latina and tribal
women um who work in technology Fields
so they've been using the portal to
answer questions like which colleges are
graduating um or which colleges have
large numbers of women of color
graduating with computer science degrees
um which these colleges are tribal
colleges or HBCU and also how this
changing over time
uh I also recently found out that a
friend of mine whose mom is a middle
school principal in New Jersey had been
using the portal to answer questions
like how do you student test scores in
my district or in my school compared to
other schools across the district how do
they compare to um other schools across
the state another question I found that
she been answering with the portal
lately is how has this changed over the
course of the pandemic which um again
think that's a question a lot of
teachers and a lot of Administrators are
thinking about so having this data at
her fingertips has been helpful for her
the last example I want to talk about um
is particularly fun fun many layers of
Education example but um a colleague of
mine was recently a couple months ago
was picking up her kid from school and
she was wearing an urban Institute
branded fleece and another parent came
up to her and was like oh do you work at
Urban um I actually work at PBS and like
I don't know if you've heard but like
Urban makes this great tool called the
Education data portal and we've been
using it to pull geocoded lists of
schools and school districts to think
about how that maps to our our
broadcasting coverage and they talked
about ways to um use data on school
funding to specifically identify under
resource schools to think about how that
maps to um where PBS is prioritizing
their broadcast
coverage um so these are just three of
uh three of thousands of questions that
users are answering of the portal and
graph is probably pretty tiny but last
month you can see 4,000 unique users
we're here I'm using IP addresses as a
proxy for users because we don't collect
that data
um but what I think is interesting or I
think lots of things are interesting
about this one I think is just the fact
that as much as I would love to believe
that everyone is using the art package
and everyone's using the data Explorer
ultimately that's just a very small
number of the folks who are using the
portal every month um the vast majority
are coming from folks who are either
directly connecting from the API so
that's using um python or JavaScript or
other applications or other programming
languages that we don't have packages
for but what a lot of that also is is
folks who are building their own powerbi
or Tableau or whatever other kinds of
dashboards or other kinds of um user
interfaces to build their own tools to
help folks who they're one step closer
to answer their own
questions so ultimately while I think
folks in this room who are data
scientists or data Engineers it comes
really natural to us to think about
building tools for other data scientists
or other Engineers um similarly as our
programmers or python programmers it
might be really natural to think about
building tools for other art programmers
and python programmers
but I think that by unlocking data for
more people we can allow more questions
to find evidence-based answers
ultimately drive impact in the places
that folks are
working thanks so
[Applause]
much I also have a slightly unreasonable
number of hex stickers so if any that I
would love to not team pack to DC with
me so if anyone's interested thank you
so much Erica give her a round of
[Applause]
applause